na ja es ist natürlich insofern erst
einmal wirklich bitter weil wir ja in
den letzten wochen und monaten unfassbar
große anstrengungen gemacht haben um
hygiene und co auch perfekt in der gast
so wie soll man sagen nicht nur
darzustellen sondern auch zu leben und
das ist natürlich schon ein mentaler
rückschlag auch weil und das darf ich
schon zu sagen ich habe uns in der
gastronomie eigentlich als teil des
gesundheits- oder hygiene konzeptes
schon gesehen denn wenn die gäste zu uns
kommen und da möchte ich auch die tiere
vor zwei tagen das rkw dass er gesagt
hat wir in der gastronomie sind kann im
pandemie 3 war was ein großes kompliment
an die gesamte branche ist aber wenn wir
natürlich geschlossen werden dann müssen
wir damit rechnet hast die gäste wohin
gehen natürlich nach hause und da ist im
moment die größte ansteckungsgefahr
das heißt ich empfand uns als jene
konzept situation so gut aufgestellt
dass wir genau diese sorgsamkeit
gegenüber hingehen und anstrengungen
eigentlich eher unterstützen weil die
leute bei uns sage mal kontrolliert und
das ist ja das was wir heute wollen
kontrolliert eben aus dem haus gehen
sowohl in der gastro als auch in der
veranstaltungsbranche hat man sich jetzt
zusammengeschlossen gestern für eine
demonstration
dort sagte einer der teilnehmer unter
anderem man versteht natürlich dass es
maßnahmen gibt vor allem der
veranstaltungsbranche dass man da nichts
machen darf aber verständnis für
maßnahmen etwas anderes als dass man
dann vielleicht trotzdem wütend
enttäuscht ist auf die regierung dass
man jetzt so gemeinsam bestraft wird für
die paar schwarzen schafe wie ist das
bei ihnen wie wütend ist man tatsächlich
auch persönlich wenn man das jetzt hört
na ja ich würde mal sagen wütend ist
natürlich noch die stufe die nach kommt
im moment bin ich immer nur noch sauer
und zwar aus folgenden gründen weil
durch die maßnahmen die die regierung
vor wochen und monaten beschlossen hat
kommt ja ein moment und zwar dass die
kontroll situation nicht wirklich
ausreichend auch durchgeführt wurde das
heißt das so genannte schwarze schaf
wurde einfach mega index noch salopp
gesagt ammann und jetzt mache ich mal
veranstaltungs technisch ein durchaus
einen vergleich ich darf ja auch mit
meinem veranstalter seit ein paar jahren
so 20 30 auftritte im jahr auf den
verschiedensten bühnen machen mit meinem
programm und wenn ich jetzt sage ich
möchte ihnen in berlin in den
admiralspalast und wir das in 500 leute
drin 2003 passen alle mit maske sehr
hoher raum gute umluft und so weiter
hieß es nein wenn du aber dann parallel
natürlich auch und das ist das es daten
merkst dass veranstaltung im privaten
sektor
ich möchte mich da ganz vorsichtig
ausdrücken mehr oder weniger unter den
augen des ordnungsamts berlin
stattgefunden haben
in wo weder ein hygiene konzept in
ausreichender form noch masken irgendwo
da waren dann verstehe ich eben
veranstalter das hat leute hier wurde
ich im grunde an der nase herum geführt
also der staat muss natürlich schon auch
wenn er maßnahmen nicht nur erhebt dann
muss auch dafür sorgen dass diese auch
wirklich eingehalten werden und da ist
natürlich schon gerade in den großen
städten ganz plan nicht eine super
herausforderung aber mir wurde ein paar
dinge versäumt und das ist das was einen
so ja eher frustriert und auf dem boden
so unterzieht dass man sagt also mehr
als was man gemacht haben geht
eigentlich nicht dann kommen immer die
deppen daher und dann wirst du doppelt
bestraft
ja das sehen wahrscheinlich sehr viele
leute jetzt so in der gastrobranche
vielen dank alexander herrmann dass sie
nochmal ihre meinung hier so klar
gemacht haben
auch betroffene eine gleichheit und
natürlich noch sagen es gibt ja im
moment die situation dass die regierung
gesagt hat mit 70 beziehungsweise 75
prozent werden die betriebe unterstützt
man muss ganz klar sagen wenn dem
wirklich so zutrifft dann ist das
sicherlich da muss man auch kompliment
an die regierung sagen ist das
sicherlich ein paket nur es gibt da
diesen zusatz bis zu 50 oder eben 70
prozent und wir wissen alle wenn du
einmal irgendwas staatliches auf
angefordert hat dann stelle ich mir
folgenden wollten den zettel vor also
november letzt des jahres wenn du da
beerdigt wurde
dann hast du zuspruch auf 75 prozent
aber nur wenn du nach weiß dass du den
letzten zwölf monaten schon zu 23%
verwest bist und dann wird es am schluss
83 60 prozent also meine sorge ist ein
weg das dieses paket so gut wie es ist
und so sorgsam ist auch klingt am
schluss und das ist eine gefahr
nicht wirklich ankommen mehr nachrichten
und breaking news nur bei bate schau
dich hier das nächste video an und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren